[MUSIC]
WESLEY CHUN: Hey, developers.
Have you wondered how you can
help your sales, marketing,
and business dev coworkers
auto-generate slide
presentations out
of a set of images?
Greetings and welcome to another
episode of the G Suite show.
I'm your host, Wesley Chun.
Today we're going to show
you how to do just that.
Slideshows have come a long way,
from hand shadows in the cave
since fire was invented.
Then shadow puppetry
of civilized men
to the magic lanterns of the
17th through 19th centuries.
And Uncle Bob's endless family
vacation on 35-millimeter
slides.
And finally to
today's generation
of tools like
PowerPoint, Keynote,
and, of course, Google Slides.
While presentation software
are end user applications,
some are programmable.
PowerPoint provides a COM
server, where VB, C, or even
Python can be used to create PPT
files or drive presentations.
Now we can take
this to the cloud
by coding Google Slides with
Apps Script, a customized
version of JavaScript that
runs in Google's cloud,
giving you access to G
Suite services, like slides.
As previously advertised,
today's code sample
is a short script that
creates a slide presentation
from a collection of images.
We're going to walk
through a simple version
first, then add a few
more lines to make it just
a little bit more useful.
Let's go to the computer
now and take a look.
Jumping right in,
we've got lines one
through two, which name your
slide deck, both the file
name and the title
of the presentation.
Line two specifically
creates the slide deck.
Note the commented
out part here.
We'll skip it for now,
but we'll tell you what
it means before we wrap up.
Lines 4 through 7 is the
add image slide function.
It takes a URL and index.
And we'll be using this
with for each later.
For every image, we're
going to add a new slide
and then insert the image.
The first part of main,
from lines 9 to 16,
link to each image
to create slides for.
17 to 19 grab the title
and subtitle text boxes,
then sets the string
values for both.
20 loops through
the images, creating
slides for each by
calling add image slide.
So if you save it
and run it, you'll
see that it basically works.
After authorizing the script
to gain access to your Google
Slides, you'll see
in your drive folder
that it creates
our presentation--
My favorite images.
And, if you open
it up, you'll see
that we have all of our
images, but in the upper left.
Not so great, right?
Let's get rid of this,
and add seven more lines
to center the images,
making it much more useful.
So what did we do?
The new lines, 7 through 10,
grab the height and width
of each image, as well
as the slide page.
Then 11 through 13
make the calculations
to center the image on
both the x- and y-axes.
And that's it.
If we run this again, and take a
look at the slide presentation,
you'll see we get
another slide deck.
Nearly identical.
But the images are
where we want them,
making this script and the slide
decks it generates presentable
right away.
Isn't that cool?
And that's it.
As you saw, when it was just
two major lines of code,
it did its job.
But adding a few more
lines made it a lot better.
Well, if you want to
dig deeper into the code
sample and the app itself, check
out the corresponding tutorial.
Now this script is known
as a standalone app,
because it's not tied to
any specific document.
While standalone apps are useful
for demos or personal use,
they're harder to share
to a wider audience,
because the only way to
do it is cut and paste.
Well, if you want to distribute
your apps, this isn't scalable.
With a few changes,
you can turn them
into add-ons, scripts that
can be published publicly
for anyone to
install, or privately
to your own G Suite domain.
Remember that line of code
that was commented out?
Well, if you use that call,
plus some additional required
boilerplate, you'll have an
ad on that you can publish.
Check out the docs
for more info.
Your next steps?
Well, you can jump
straight into the docs
and brainstorm your
own magic lantern app.
Or if you want to learn
more about Apps Script?
Well, check out our other
videos that show you
what else you can do with it.
Want to build an app
for Google Slides
outside of the Apps
Script environment
and with your own
development tools?
Well, then, you want to
use a slide's REST API.
And, of course, we've
got another set of videos
to show you how to use that.
Got our sample app working?
Well, before you start
on your own project,
I want to challenge you.
Instead of hard-coding
online images,
well, tweak our app to use
images on your Google Drive.
Or, even more powerful, use
a drive file picker dialog,
and let your users choose.
Well, let us know how
you do in the comments.
The sky's the limit
on what you can
do with slides in Apps Script.
Thanks for tuning in.
And send us your
suggestions on what
you'd like to see in
future episodes down below.
This is Wesley Chun from Google,
and we'll see you upstairs
in the G Suite.
[MUSIC PLAYING]